[Music]
okay everybody i am so so excited today
because i am joined by the one and only
eleanor lambert aka jenny in time now
which is in theaters and on demand now
how you doing today eleanor i am great
thank you so much for having me on thank
you for oh no lovely introduction
of course i'm thank you for coming on
i'm so excited to talk to you i
absolutely love this film and really the
first thought that came to my mind when
i was interviewing was like this must be
so exciting for you because you're
starring in this mystery thriller that
just premiered at the austin film
festival
is this is this like a dream come true
for you i mean it's it was
from start to finish it was pretty much
the most ideal
for for real first um job i could have
ever dreamed of i got you know i'm the
lead which is like when spencer asked me
to do this i was like are you did you
call the right person like are you sure
it was so cool and and from you know
like i said from start to finish being
being on set with such um amazing
amazing people i mean
every single person
was 10 out of 10 was so dedicated so
driven so present
spencer said in an interview that we did
together he was like everybody wanted to
be there
and that kind of energy is so infectious
and it keeps it keeps it light it keeps
it fun it keeps everybody really
excuse me really engaged throughout
and so and also you know being on a on a
smaller set like that
we're all in each other's business all
day long in like the best possible way i
learned so much you know as a as a
novice of the craft and and you know the
few sets i've been on have sort of been
much larger productions and you're sort
of
put in your trailer and kept there until
you're needed and this was super cool
because i got to learn so much about how
you know how this industry really works
on the inside so it was really really
amazing
oh yeah and that's interesting you keep
mentioning too about it being like a
smaller project and intimate and you're
having fun on set but that you've had
experience on bigger projects for people
first seeing you perform in this film a
lot of them are probably going to wonder
you know are you someone who's
interested in doing like lead roles in
big projects like is that something you
want to do down the road or you kind of
like stuck like you want to do indies
like what's your kind of well i mean i
want to work i'm just so excited to
finally be able to say i i picked a
thing and i'm gonna do it now and like
you know things take things like that
take time i think you know we're asked
to make these big life decisions when
we're
17 18 19 even 23 is
anyway i'm i'm just i want to work i'm
so excited to be embarking on this and
so
i'm i'm i'm like i will do give me i
will do it
i love that no i think i can do it now
you know finally
building up that that confidence kind of
it's it's it's
it's a journey
yeah much on of course i think we all
are but anyway
yeah that's such a good positive vibe to
have too and i like you mentioned that
you were saying that it was like
positive vibes on set and it i love
hearing stories like that because this
is a very heavy emotional movie you know
it put me in a dark place a bit um so
i'm wondering for your craft and doing
the role of jenny did you find a lot you
can relate to in such a like dark
storyline or did you have to kind of go
places maybe not too familiar
well that's a great question um
i would say that
jenny is
very different from eleanor like we
could not be more different at least
internally and experience like in our
daily lives and how we respond to the
situations and experiences of our lives
um very different
so that kind of closed off
lack the closed-off quality of jenny and
the sort of lack of intimacy that she
she deliberately cultivates in her life
she keeps everybody
at a distance because she is also at a
distance
inside of herself you know so
i think
there were a couple moments you know i'm
i i
you know when i'm
off camera and on set i definitely
couldn't keep the like
i'm in my zone okay because i'm just
this is not me and so i was hanging out
with people and then i was like okay i
need to take like you know my take a
little bit of time and get back into the
headspace but
i think what actually really helped this
was we shot this entire movie in 15 days
so
we were like
so by the end of the days
my decompression time was shortened and
in a in a way that i think really served
me because i didn't get an opportunity i
didn't have you know three days i did i
did have some obviously some days off it
wasn't anything like horrendous or
legal obviously i just mean
you know when you make a movie that that
quickly i didn't have
so much time to like
let her go and then have to bring her
back so in that sense
i think
i did get to sort of stay in that
mindset on it on a sort of overall
but you know i did have to go to some
dark places and i think
that
i think that
now when i did this film i was
six months into my first year of acting
training which in the meisner technique
is essentially untraining it's
deep deconditioning yourself to allow
yourself to have an authentic experience
um
and like getting into your gut really
and so when i
when i showed up to do this movie i
basically had i had like less of an idea
of what i thought i what i thought i
needed to do which
like you know like i said really i think
helped me because
that's jenny jenny is out of adjustment
jenny is a little bit she's a bit of a
odd odd bird and i like that about her
but
um this is all just to say that
now
having just finished finally you know my
my two-year program which was
slated to end in 2020 of course like
everyone was in the middle of something
in march of 2020 and uh i literally had
my last acting class last night we
finally got back together
it's unbelievable but now that i've
completed that and there are there are
some more tools in my tool chest that
i'm excited to get to use i'll just say
that and i wouldn't change a single
thing about
about the the the entire process of from
from pre-production um spencer and
claudia black and i all got on the phone
and we were chatting all the time and
that also really helped to sort of you
know you start building the world to be
able to start building the world with
the director and with another lead in
the film
that helped also to sort of get into
that mindset but anyway i'm i'm totally
rambling so i'm gonna no i'm enjoying it
you're you're you're great at this and i
i'm
impressed too because you're you're
bringing up a lot of interesting stuff
so i'm trying to catch it all because
i'm like oh i want to ask her about that
i want to throw out that sorry
um i i think too that it's interesting
you're talking about like just finishing
an acting class so
i know from research i've done before
this interview that you you know
previously started with modeling i don't
know if this is accurate or not because
i think i found this on wikipedia but
that you also study journalism
okay so now i feel like you're judging
my journalist skills while i'm doing
this i'm going to pretend i don't know
that but um
i guess
no
but um is is acting though really like
what the end of the day your true love
is that you want to do are you kind of
someone you like you have a bunch of
things you like doing like i know it's
true i have sort of dabbled into
different i would say professional
tracks because i don't know if they ever
turned into proper professions for me
i so my first love was writing i was
writing when i was a wee one because it
was just fun and
and free and that was i love words i
love i love
i love words i love being able i love
language and and the beauty of language
and being able to express however i do
find this format
to be something i at this stage of my
life feel much more comfortable with i'm
a talker i like to talk conversation
flows much more easily obviously in a
conversation wow what a surprise then in
an article
however
i would say in terms of modeling i mean
modeling was
fun and what i loved about modeling is
kind of what i'm learning i love about
almost everything is
i love the set i love the communal
aspect i love meeting people from across
the world and i love feeling just like
a cog in a wheel like everybody on set
one person didn't show up the whole
thing falls apart and like and that sort
of reciprocity on set of like i am here
for you and you are here for me and we
are here for each other like
loved that
but what i think my my real true love is
understanding
human experience
and
so you know i didn't i didn't know that
until later in my life so i didn't have
an opportunity to study psychology or
neuro neuroscience or
you know the crosstalk the crosses
between spirituality and psychology and
those are sort of my like i could just
like my book shelf is like all that like
okay there's a theme here get it if
anyone comes over like there's no
mystery what i'm interested in but but
acting
is kind of you know the outside in
version of that like i am fascinated by
the mechanisms and the and the neural
the the neurotransmitters and
the inner the inner workings and i want
to understand that from a scientific my
mind wants to understand that from a
scientific standpoint
but acting is really very much the
outside inversion you get to see
somebody emote and have and manifest
their experience and then you get to go
what is going on in there
right right
the way that you're doing it so in that
sense acting is like
definitely i'm i definitely my passion
in terms of
because it does hit me in my
natural kind of curiosity about yeah you
know and that's also that's what i loved
about this film in particular because
jenny is our main character
she's who we follow throughout the film
but she introduces us to everybody else
in the film and we get these amazing
snapshots of
all different kinds of people
going through this one single event this
one tragedy this traumatic event and i
thought spencer captured very well
and each character captured very well um
just the myriad ways that people respond
to trauma and how of course like i mean
just even you and i
in this interview we're gonna have two
totally different experiences of this
interview obviously because we're two
different people and i think that
if you can capture that in a film
especially with a lot of characters in
this film and
and and but they're all unified in this
one
tragedy um
and i think you know to see that sort of
splintering but also that
the unity of it it was that's what i
really liked that's what really drew me
to this and and especially now the more
that i've i've seen it and
i'm able to talk about it you know in
these interviews and the more i think
about it i think that that is a real
feat of the film is how
how we get to
you know we get to see the person who
takes on all the guilt of something like
this we get to see the person who is
like
will not engage will not process we see
the person who dives into the work and
the dream that was built before this
happened and so we've got just got joan
who's the caretaker and so we've got
this like interesting
yeah interesting snapshot of a lot of
different psyches
yeah 100 and i think that's the best
part about the film and you mentioned
two before claudia black and i think my
favorite scenes were between you and her
and having that fairy godmother i just
have to say that i love oh yeah my whole
oh yeah
no you guys together just clicked
perfectly but did that come right away
was there you know a process you were
learning through with her like to how do
you guys to get in sync like that just
or did i just magically fall into place
it magically fell into place i know that
that's the most annoying thing i've ever
heard but we went out
we went out to a lunch we were we were
all staying at the same hotel and
i never met her you know and we were
about to film like the next day and so
i was like do you want to go get some
huevos rancheros so there's a place i'm
obsessed with i like was like i'm gonna
find the best wave i was in detroit and
i found them and they were so good
and i was like do you want to come with
me and
and from that
meal
i don't know we were just like
oh my god like
are we best friends like i think we're
messed up like it was one of those just
hell yeah i can't even describe i i've
never really you know i'm i'm i'm 28 i'm
i'm still a very young person and she is
as well and but i had never really had
that because i grew up with all my
friends and i have basically you know
aside from you know
my partner and the people i've been so
lucky to meet through him but most of my
friends yeah i've known forever so to
make that kind of a connection that was
just so
immediate and so so genuine i was oh i
love her it was it was literally like
just like yeah yeah it was no i
i think that's awesome and i i think
just not just with you and how you do
with claudia but just the whole
performance you manning this film being
the lead you did such a good job and
what runs through my head too is i i
also think there's a credit to it that
you know you have two parents that are
actors did you feel that there is like
an added pressure whenever you act now
because of that like do you do that are
you able to just kind of tune it out
like how has that been has that been a
challenge it's definitely there it lives
in my brain it's a little voice that you
know compares compares comparison i
think we all have that in our respective
professions and that is you know one of
the tasks of
being alive is is un deconditioning some
of those downloaded
you know things that we get from the
overculture of just
you know perfectionism and
and and and and the form something takes
as opposed to the substance of it and i
think that
but at the same time it's like
i have to you know i know i have to turn
that off i know that's doing me such a
disservice and and and keeping me from
connecting to something inside myself
and
you know that's the work that's that
that's the internal sort of work of an
artist of anyone who's
putting their work out there in any in
any capacity you know
but
there is a little bit of that you know
it was funny i had my last acting class
last last night we had you know we had
our sweet kind of debrief with our
teacher
she was she was a friend of mine in the
class was talking about and she also
echoed this kind of interesting thing
that can happen like oh no oh i don't i
don't do class i'm a natural this kind
of like natural thing and power to you
if you are and like that's awesome
but
for me it's been so crucial to have
tools in my tool chest that when
i'm like starting to feel that internal
like oh god oh god i'm not connecting or
something doesn't feel quite right i can
go
yeah we know what's the circumstance you
know like i have my
tools which just help for
help for me and then you know this made
me think of something else if that's
okay i know i'm just like
no no about something in the film
um
something else that i really loved about
this film was
like i said you know you we download
these sort of like
do this don't do this you're not allowed
to if you're not the best don't bother
trying it's like what even is the best
but
i think that we see in this film
the way that
society culture whatever patriarchy has
taught us
that some of the
feelings that we just so naturally have
as people are like bad or wrong or
shameful
and that's not to say that they're not
unpleasant and we don't want to you know
eventually move through and beyond them
hopefully
but
when we start to and i think this is
what happened to jenny so deeply and
when we start to
shoot ourselves with that second arrow
right we have this like difficult
feeling inside of ourselves and then we
go and shame on you and you're not
supposed to your job is to
fill in the blank and it's like my job
is to have my feelings and be present
with myself and so
and we're not taught that and we're not
given tools to
heal we have to if we want to heal
whatever that may be we have to really
actively seek it out you know it's not
readily available for people we don't
have
those those resources and it requires
money and time and
so
i just think that you know jenny is sort
of this tragic snapshot of what can
happen when
you
just
don't give yourself any space
to
have your feelings and you just go nope
not engaging over and over and over
again right right with no intimate
connection with anybody in your life
including your child her child you know
there's not one moment of
real intimacy between them and i
remember being like
ouch you know but
you know and it culminates in this
ultimate act of
more harm and you know hurting people
hurting people and
you know
i think there's an opportunity for
people to heal each other and help and
and so you know on the flip side of this
very dark story is the alternative also
you know under you walk away with the
what could have happened if it didn't go
like that if jenny didn't run from her
feelings if we didn't go
no
to our own experience you know
yeah i mean that that's just great
wisdom right there and i think you make
a really good point there at the end too
that like
everything you're saying is tran we can
translate that through the language of
film and that you go away with that
hopefully learn something a better
person and how do we learn it if we're
not you know going to someone else's
life and living it that's i guess
then you're the one you know translating
i could just like feel your love of film
through the scriptures
i'm rolling off of you so
i have one more question before if you
have more time for one more question yes
i haven't like been ranting away i no i
i had to ask you this so
you can correct me wrong but i'm pretty
sure you're a new york based actress
right so okay so i'm in new york too i
love when i talk to new york uh talent
and i always feel like for upcoming
actresses and actors you know they
always want to like run to l.a so i
wanted to ask you like being that you've
been in new york do you like can you
kind of give us like maybe the case for
why like what's that advantage of being
in new york as an oh sure i think it
gets a bad rap if that makes sense it i
would say so and there's you know back
in the day yes you needed to physically
be in hollywood because that's where
that was happening but
first of all everything seems to be
shooting in canada and obviously canada
is huge but if it's in toronto it's like
right there so that's good true
um but i would say you know new york is
there's no place like new york
other cities have like equality here and
the choir like put four cities together
and it's kind of similar to new york but
in terms of that energy
that is something that i think actors
really
need we need because a lot of acting at
the beginning especially
is waiting for the opportunity to act
and is waiting to put these tools and
all the doing that you want to do
into action and
we need to keep our kind of keep our
souls fed we need to keep moving we need
to be seeing art we need to be going and
looking at the water at sunset and
something
about l.a i just get a little sleepy out
there there's a sleepy kind of energy if
you're not consistently working it's
like i gotta get in my car and sit in
the traffic to just to go look at the
ocean and it's like right
maybe i won't do that today because i'm
like i'm in my apartment in west
hollywood and i'm just not gonna do that
today and then
but
on a slightly more more serious note or
or more technical note everything is i
mean obviously everything is over
zoom now i haven't been in an audition
room since 2020 very early 2020
obviously and
and that's kind of that what a gift you
can submit from basically anywhere
i mean yeah with with some restrictions
obviously in terms of like local hires
and covet things you know i do
understand that they don't want you
don't want to be like totally just like
traveling all the time but that what
what an amazing gift to give to give
yourself some some freedom to be able to
and so much is happening out here
also you're going to like get on i get
auditions from l.a
right you over here you know so i don't
know i mean it's tough for me because
this city
it's been 10 years across 10 years in
new york in august which is just are you
from new york
yes oh my gosh born and born and bred
that's so cool can i ask where
uh ups a little upstate like um and now
i mean that's your good vibes right
there it's the other side that i'm
getting it's just i mean i love i love a
new yorker like of course but yeah yeah
that's much more of energy i'm so
grateful oh thank you thank you thank
you it feels like such a lovely
interview but that's what i would say
about new york thank you
yeah i love it and that that gives
everyone who has doubts of going to l.a
you know stay in new york ride it out
you're going to get rewarded and i mean
it's an ass kicker of a city and that's
also helpful it keeps you in motion
they're like okay we're moving so i get
it
i love it um
but yeah everyone you got to see the
lovely eleanor lambert here she gives so
much free wisdom here this is free
there's no patreon you get this for free
enjoy it take notes um but you know if
you loved even just listening to her you
got to watch her just kick total butt
here in time now which is in theaters
and on demand now eleanor thank you so
much for joining us today and i hope to
talk to you again in the future one day
oh me too this was so nice